l' enquête sur la disparition de la
petite estelle en région parisienne elle
a donné lieu à la plus importantes
opérations de police jamais menée dans
les milieux pédophiles 75
interpellations
toutes les personnes déjà condamnées et
qui ont un lien plus ou moins direct
avec la zone de disparition ont été
entendus avec de la monnaie bruno bini
et chloé lecomte région il fait encore
nuit tôt ce matin blessé policiers sont
déjà à pied d'oeuvre dans cette maison
de seine et marne
les enquêteurs ont fouillé chaque recoin
pour trouver des indices vêtements des
stèles coupures de presse mais ils vont
surtout saisir le disque dur de
l'ordinateur à la recherche
d'éventuelles images pédophiles
le locataire de cette maison a déjà été
poursuivi pour attouchements sexuels
il fait partie d'une des 84 cibles
visées par cette large descente de
police en effet au même instant
l'opération se répète dans toute la
france comme ici à lille au total 450
policiers ont été mobilisés
ce n'est pas une opération de la
dernière chance parce que l' enquête
seraient au point mort que l'or ne
saurait plus quoi faire
ce n'est absolument pas sans nous sommes
dans la logique d'une enquête d'une
enquête au long cours
les suspects sont ensuite emmenés en
garde à vue ils vont être interrogés sur
leur emploi du temps
le 9 janvier 2003 jour de la disparition
d'estelle
ils vont également subir un prélèvement
de salive destiné à alimenter le fichier
adn de la police le décret qui le leur
permet est tout frais il a été publié
hier au journal officiel
les enquêteurs n'ont pas perdu une
minute mais malgré la diffusion en juin
dernier du portrait robot d'un suspect
malgré les efforts des dix-sept
policiers permanents de la cellule
estelle l'enquète n'a toujours pas
abouti ce soir la plupart des suspects
ont été relâchés mais pour la police il
ya déjà un point positif le nombre de
pédophiles recensés dans le fichier des
empreintes génétiques a augmenté